في هذه الاثناء قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انتني بلان ان بلاده تدعم
الجهود الدبلوماسيه الراميه الى تحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا واضافه في كلمه خلال
جلسه افتراضيه بشان السلامه في اوكرانيا
نوع واشنطن ملتزمه بتحقيق السلام الذي
يحفظ سياده اوكرانيا ووحده اراضيها
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بدعم الجهد
الدبلوماسيه الهادفه لتحقيق السلام ونعلم
جميعا ان السلام العادل يحتم التمسك
بالمبادئ الموجوده في صميم ميثاق الامم
المتحده وهي السياده وحده الاراضي
والاستقلال ولكي يكون السلام دائما يجب ان
يضمن عدم قدره روسيا على اراحه قواتها
واعاده التجهيزها وشن الحرب في وقت يصب في
مصلحتها اوكرانيا قدمت مقترحا من شانه ان
يحقق مثل هذا السلام وينهي الحرب وينقذ
ارواحا كثيره